[Music]
good evening america
i'm proud to be here in cold washington
to see tonight
i want to offer this small prayer for
our country this is land
of hope and dreams
grab your ticket and your suitcase
thunder's rolling down this track
you don't know where you're going now
but you know you won't be back darling
if you're weary
lay your head upon my chest
we'll take what we can carry
and we'll leave the rest
well big wheels roll through fields
where sunrise streams
meet me in a land of hope
and dreams
yeah well i will provide for you
oh and i'll stand by your side
you'll need a good companion now
[Music]
let's let this day be the last
well tomorrow will be sunshine and
sunshine
and all this darkness passed
well big wheels roll through fields
where
sunlight streams
oh meet me
in a land of hope
carry saints and sinners
this train carries losers and winners
this tree carries hearts and gamblers
this train
carries low souls i said this train
dreads will not be thwarted
this tree faith will
be rewarded on this train
hear the steel wheels singing this train
bells of freedom ringing
the big wheels roll through fields where
sunlight streaks
o meet me in a land of hope
and dreams
meet me in a land
[Music]
please welcome our host tom hanks
bruce springsteen's land of hope and
dreams kicks off tonight celebrating
america
on this day which saw the inauguration
of our 46th
president joseph r biden jr i'm at the
lincoln memorial
on the national mall in our nation's
secured capital city
in the last few weeks in the last few
years
we've witnessed deep divisions and a
troubling rancor
in our land but tonight
we ponder the united states of america
the practice of our democracy the
foundations of our republic
the integrity of our constitution
the hope and dreams we all share
for a more perfect union
to sum a presidential inauguration is a
tradition
an act that marks the commitment of a
new
four-year term yet in truth inauguration
day
is about much more than the swearing-in
of our next
national leaders this day is about
witnessing
the permanence of our american ideal
every four years we hear the words that
will
empower us all on the journey ahead
a message that can unite us as we begin
a new passage from where we are
to where we can be a trek
to a common goal to the promise
of our promised land the keynote of this
day is the presidential inaugural
address
the new president republican democrat
lays out a vision for the nation if the
words ring out
it is not only due to the power of the
oratory
it is because the dream of america has
no limits
and resonates well beyond any single day
tonight we share memorable passages from
the inaugural remarks
of four of our past presidents each
spoke to a specific moment in our
history
fdr rallied us in the great depression
jfk inspired a new generation
to serve ronald reagan spoke of the
peaceful
transition of power for a shining city
on a hill
and abraham lincoln sought to unite us
after a war that tore us apart
with malice toward none with charity
for all with firmness in the right
as god gives us to see the right let us
strive on
to finish the work we are in to bind up
the nation's wounds
to care for him he shall have borne the
battle and for his widow
and his orphan to do all which may
achieve and cherish
a just and lasting peace among ourselves
and with all nations this great nation
will endure as it has endured
will revive and will prosper
so first of all let me assert
my firm belief that the only thing
that we have to fear is fear itself
in the long history of the world only a
few generations have been granted the
role of defending freedom and it's our
maximum danger i do not shrink from this
responsibility
i welcome it i do not believe that any
of us would exchange
places with any other people or any
other generation
the energy the faith the devotion which
we bring to this endeavor
will light our country in all who serve
it
and the glow from that fire can truly
light the world
and so my fellow americans ask
not what your country can do for you
ask what you can do for your country
to a few of us here today this is a
solemn and most momentous occasion
and yet in the history of our nation it
is a commonplace occurrence
the orderly transfer of authority as
called for in the constitution
routinely takes place as it has for
almost two centuries
and few of us stop to think how unique
we really are
in the eyes of many in the world this
every four-year ceremony
we accept as normal is nothing less than
a miracle
we'll celebrate america with more
performances
and tributes to the men and women across
the country who have provided strength
and kept us going through hardships
and troubled times ahead
president biden speaks to the nation
coming up more great music and we
recognize
outstanding service by our citizens on
celebrating america
[Music]
i'm eva longoria over the last three
days americans have honored the start of
this
new chapter by reaffirming our
commitment to some of our nation's
highest ideals
community empathy and democracy
it began with our national day of
service on monday martin luther king jr
day
when americans across the country
volunteered in their neighborhoods
providing covet 19 relief and addressing
issues highlighted by the pandemic in
pursuit of the economic and
social justice that dr king envisioned
in his beloved community
yesterday the presidential inaugural
committee hosted a ceremony at the
lincoln memorial reflecting pool
to honor those who have died during the
pandemic it was a powerful moment to
remember our loved ones
and renew our commitment to work
together to end the pandemic
and rebuild our nation and earlier today
we took part in some of the most
important moments in the continuing
evolution of our democracy
from the swearing-in ceremony to the
president's speech to the parade across
america and the procession
to the white house we've been reminded
that it's our responsibility as citizens
to protect
and build a more inclusive democracy
every day
hi joseph robinette biden jr do solemnly
swear
that i will faithfully execute and i
will faithfully execute
the office of president of the united
states office of president of the united
states
so help you god so help me god
congratulations mr president
[Applause]
[Music]
the world is watching so here's my
message to those beyond our borders
america has been we've come out stronger
for it
to the new yorker i pledge allegiance
to the united states
of and i america well
and faithfully the duties of the office
on which i am about to enter the beauty
of the office upon which i am about
soccer
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
grace
[Music]
show the way the way of unity
we can see each other not as adversaries
but as neighbors
we can treat each other with dignity and
respect
we can join forces stop the shouting and
lower the temperature
this is our historic moment of crisis
and challenge
and unity is the path forward
[Music]
is
if we merge mercy with mites
and mites with rights then love
becomes our legacy and change
our children's birth life
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to celebrating america here
are some exceptional americans who have
stepped up
they are the indispensable folks who
provide the daily services
we too often take for granted
[Music]
i think the essential workers carry the
rest of us on their shoulders through
these many months
the grocery store clerks the delivery
clerks the drivers
the folks on the assembly line the
meatpack too
often overlooked given the best to their
country
and we need them the most that's the
american we know
that's who we are
[Music]
good evening i'm anthony gaskin in the
halsey neighborhood just outside of
richmond virginia
and i deliver packages to the people who
live here and tonight i'm honored to
represent
the many front line workers across our
nation who keep america going
it's not only a job for us but we care
about the people who live here
and know that their concern for us and
our safety
and now i have a special delivery for
you
from miami john bon jovi
[Music]
it's all right
[Music]
it's been a long cold lonely winter
[Music]
here comes the sun and i'd say
it's all right
[Music]
little darling
[Music]
[Music]
here
it's all right
[Music]
here it comes
sun sun sun here it comes
the sun sun here it comes
sunset
[Music]
little darling i feel that ice is slowly
melting
little darling it seems like
it since it's been clear
here comes the
[Music]
it's all right
here comes the sun
[Music]
it's all right
[Music]
it's all right
[Music]
do
fellow americans i'm united states
marine corps sergeant brennan lombardo
and i'm an aviation operations
specialist stationed at marine corps air
station
iwakuni japan over here we're focused on
protecting and defending our original
allies partners
in the united states of america our
joint forces are committed to preserving
security
stability and freedom no matter what
challenges we face
nowhere stationed more than 6 000 miles
away in the asia pacific
we're truly honored to celebrate the
ceremony with you congratulations to our
new commander-in-chief
semper fidelis ura coming up
more fantastic performances and tributes
to our everyday heroes
on celebrating america
[Music]
good evening everybody and now for some
good news
every night all these people have been
cheering on the health care workers
during their shift change
[Music]
the small army of citizens making mass
new york's finest cheering on
out-of-state healthcare workers
the tick-tock doc spreading positivity
during a pandemic
some are using these dark days to create
some bright bulb
ideas copit19 has tapped a creative
nerve
that many of us never even knew we had
the dance move flossing very beautiful
what you both are doing
during a crisis you know cocktail hour
can be almost any hour
drive-by celebrations have become quite
popular during these times
dj kopeck says he raised 1 million
dollars for the baltimore child abuse
center a leading artist
offers us songs of comfort this is just
something
that i can do
[Music]
we have been tested these last 10 months
as individuals
families and communities but
in the midst of devastation and loss
there were moments
when a flickering light pointed us
toward a brighter future
you brought us comfort you sustained us
and so that light grew and became
a bright beam in the universe
this is for all of you who found new
ways
for us to smile together
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
mm-hmm
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now it is my honor to introduce the
president of the united states
joseph r biden jr
hello all the participants tonight event
it's humbling to stand here in this
place in front of these sacred words
humbling out of respect to president
lincoln and the office
we now share and humbling because of you
the american people
as i said earlier today we have learned
again that democracy is precious
because of you democracy has prevailed
that's why jill and i kamlin doug wanted
to make sure our inauguration was not
about us
but about you the american people this
is a great nation
we're good people and to overcome the
challenges in front of us requires the
most
elusive of all things in a democracy
unity
requires us to come together in common
love that defines us
as americans opportunity
liberty dignity and respect and to unite
against common foes
hate violence disease and hopelessness
america's story depends not on any one
of us
not on some of us but on all of us on we
the people that's the task before us
the only way we'll get through the
darkness around us
there are moments in our history when
more is asked of us as
americans we saw that in the civil war
we saw that with dr king dreaming
from these steps across the mall
we are in one of those moments now the
pandemic
economic crisis racial injustice the
climate crisis
and threats to our very democracy and
the question is
are we up to it will we meet the moment
like our forebearers have
i believe we must and i believe we will
you the american people are the reason
why i've never been more optimistic
about america
than i am this very day there isn't
anything we can't do
if we do it together and that's what
you'll see
tonight stories of ordinary americans
who do
extraordinary things that's how we'll
celebrate america
and respect and represent america in our
time in
office america
america build a of decency it's built of
decency and dignity
of love and healing of greatness and
goodness
of possibilities this is a story that
guides us
inspires us and unites us today and
always
so thank you for this honor i will give
my all to you
may god bless america and may god
protect our troops
well thank you mr president throughout
tonight
we're giving special thanks to americans
who keep our nation moving forward
despite all obstacles they
are our friends and they are our
neighbors
they keep us from going hungry they
educate our children
and make sacrifices both personal and
professional
to help us all hang on for another meal
another day until next month
we could not cope without them by their
example
they encouraged many others to join them
in performing acts of kindness
and decency and the easing
of shared burdens
with love and understanding and with
small
acts of kindness you show up for each
other
in big ways and small ones again and
again
it's what so many of you are doing right
now
for your loved ones for complete
strangers for your communities
i have given 138 care packages to senior
citizens
they mean more trust than anything else
hi my name is kavanaugh bell and i
spread positivity to inspire others to
change the world
because the pandemic left so many in
need i decided to make care packs to
help elderly people
in my community and now i'm able to
gather supplies
to give to families across the country
thanks to the people who pitch in every
day to help
that's why love wins and i am so excited
to
introduce the amazing song better days
from memphis here is aunt clemens and
justin timberlake
[Music]
there's a light at the end of the tunnel
keep your eyes on the road ahead
but if you feel it lost in the night
it's okay to cry
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
holidays
[Music]
weak just be strong deep breath
stay calm if you just
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
i know you feel left out slept
on keep going keep going
shine bright don't dim yours but no one
keep going higher and higher
[Music]
better days
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you see it believe me
[Music]
okay
[Music]
is
more musical tributes from across the
nation are coming up
when celebrating america returns
tonight we honor our nation we honor the
american people's ability and desire
to come together during difficult times
to emerge
even stronger than before we wanted to
showcase the diversity and talent of our
creative community
so to celebrate the colors and that
diversity
and the beauty in our lives let's head
to the austin city limits
performing colors this is black pumas
[Music]
hello we're the black pumas from austin
texas congratulations to president biden
and vice president harris on this
historic win
we hope you enjoy the music
i walk up to the morning sky first
[Music]
baby
[Music]
till i'm clean
[Music]
[Music]
favorite colors yes ma'am
my sisters and my brothers
[Music]
my sister sent me
[Music]
[Music]
let them know what it feels to feel all
[Music]
[Music]
least i can right i'll anticipate a
homecome paradise we've been a gate in
the morning dark
sweet morning
[Music]
colors
[Music]
my sister sent my furnace
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back america to your celebration
we'll continue to recognize everyday
heroes and focus on
our nation's educators we have asked
much of them over the last year and
they've overcome
seemingly insurmountable challenges so
let's do them honor
all of them as we look at some education
educator
educators from coast to coast including
one kindergarten teacher
whose enthusiastic remote lessons became
a viral sensation
and taught us all a little something
this whole country owes teachers like
you a debt of gratitude
made an enormous sacrifice and you show
so much creativity
everything that will be possible for our
country tomorrow is going to be in large
part thanks to what you do today
the kids give me the energy that i feed
right off of them
seeing their smiles and their laughter
i do it for them good evening everyone
i'm mackenzie adams in seattle
washington like many educators my
passion is engaging young minds
whether in the classroom or through a
computer screen i happen to go viral
because of it
it's been a difficult year for our
students and i am so proud of all the
teachers
parents and students across the country
who have adapted and made the best out
of a tough time
so for all my fellow teachers for all of
my kiddos at glenwood elementary school
and for all of you
watching at home here's seattle's own
foo
fighters mackenzie adams reminds me of
another outstanding teacher who holds a
very special place in my heart
my mother virginia who is a public
school teacher for 35 years
like mackenzie and dr jill biden
she was also a mentor to her students
remembered long after their graduation
this year our teachers were faced with
unprecedented challenges
but through dedication and creativity
they faced those challenges head on
so this next song is for mackenzie and
all of our
unshakeable teachers that continue to
enlighten
our nation's kids every day this is
called
times like these
[Music]
i'm a road that drives away
follows you back home
i i'm a streetlight shine now
i'm a white light blind and bright
burn enough and known
[Music]
it's times like this you learn
to live again
it's times like these
[Music]
it's times like these
[Music]
i
[Music]
tonight
[Music]
it's times like these you learn
to live again
it's times like these
give and give again
it's times like these
learn to love again
it's times like these times
[Music]
uh
[Music]
it's just like this
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
bloopers
more music plus the vice president
kamala harris next on celebrating
america
i'm carrie washington this day has been
a long
time coming groundbreaking women have
fought for their dreams and carved the
path
and now kamala harris is the first black
and south asian woman
vice president of these united states
she is the first
but she will not be the last the future
for girls
everywhere is limitless to celebrate
this historic day
some extraordinary broadway performers
have come together to provide
inspiration
525 thousand six hundred
minutes five hundred twenty-five
thousand
moments so dear five hundred
twenty-five thousand six hundred minutes
how do you measure measure a
year in daylight in sunsets
in midnight two cups of coffee
in inches in miles and ladder and stride
[Music]
how do you measure a year in the life
measuring
five seasons twenty-five thousand six
hundred men
five hundred twenty-five thousand ten
bits of land
525 600
[Music]
the way that [ __ ] died
[Music]
shining
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
oh
[Music]
celebrating america welcome back
hunger continues to be a heartbreaking
reality
in our nation during this pandemic the
number of families who go hungry has
skyrocketed
once again there are heroes all over
america who saw the needs
and then rose to the challenges to help
their neighbors
maybe they even helped you
ending hunger and malnutrition at home
and around the world
is consequential if we do nothing today
food insecurity will loom as an even
larger and bigger threat tomorrow
you're fostering a world that is more
just and peaceful
our lemonade stand fundraiser by little
john's it gives food to families who
have food insecurity
my name is jose andres i am a chef who
believes that food is not just a luxury
for the lucky few
it's a basic human right to live free
from hunger
but today we have a hunger crisis in
america
one in four of our neighbors is going
hungry
as an immigrant and a proud american
citizen i know how americans respond to
a crisis
we step up through food banks churches
and organizations like mine wall central
kitchen
working with over 2 500 restaurants to
prepare more
than 35 million meals through this
pandemic
food is the fastest way to rebuild our
sense of community
we can put people back to work preparing
it and we can put
lives back together by fighting hunger
we need everyone to join this fight
we need longer tables not higher walls
and we need more americans like
eight-year-old
morgan marsh mcglone from belabelle
wisconsin
who set out to make america a better
place
by helping to feed people she's never
met
thank you chef andres when i learned
that kids who used to get meals at
school were going hungry because of
kovid
i wanted to open up lemonades and to
raise money to help but because of
social distancing that couldn't work
so i opted an online lemonade stand
we raise over 52 000 which means i have
to make a lot of lemonade coupons
i'm happy to be one of the many
americans helping others
and now back to tom hanks
well thanks morgan i want to be just
like you
president biden has often turned to the
words of
irish poets for solace and encouragement
in the pantheon of his favorite poets
seamus haney stands above all others
the president has frequently quoted one
poem of his
for its particular relevance inspiring
him to declare that this is our moment
to make hope
and history rhyme so now
to recite it at the united palace
theater
in his washington heights neighborhood
of new york city
here's lin-manuel miranda the cure of
troy
by sheamus heaney human beings suffer
they torture one another they get hurt
and get hard
no poem or play or song can fully right
or wrong
inflicted and endured history says don't
hope on the side of the grave
but then once in a lifetime
the longed for tidal wave of justice can
rise up
and hope and history rhyme
so hope for a great sea change on the
far side of revenge
believe that a further shore is
reachable from here
believe in miracles and cures and
healing wells
call miracle self-healing the utter
self-revealing double-take of feeling
if there's fire on the mountain and
lightning and storm
and a god speaks from the sky that means
someone is hearing the outcry
and the birth cry of new life at its
term
it means once in a lifetime that justice
can rise up
and hope and history rhyme
good evening america i'm nasa astronaut
kate rubins along with the american
members of our expedition 64 crew
aboard the international space station
we're 200 miles above
earth and traveling at 17 500 miles per
hour around its orbit
we're up here working with our
international partners to find new
scientific breakthroughs
from improved vaccines to safer drinking
water to help people all over the world
just as we're celebrating two decades of
global cooperation in space
it's truly an honor for us to celebrate
america today
as we unite for this historic inaugural
tradition that spans more than two
centuries
[Music]
coming up our friends and neighbors
across the country
join the finale of celebrating america
last night a breathtaking moment of
national unity honored the over 400
thousand lives lost to covet 19.
thousands of people in cities and small
towns participated
from san carlos apache reservation to
sally south carolina
from one world trade center to wrigley
field buildings and landmarks were
illuminated church bells rang
and in washington dc cardinal wilton
daniel gregory
offered a blessing and 400 glowing
lights surrounding the lincoln memorial
reflecting pool
sparked a nationwide flame this national
memorial to live's loss featured lori
marie key
a detroit nurse whose voice encouraged
her exhausted colleagues
and a performance by yolanda adams
[Music]
we pray for those who have died
and the families and loved ones that
they left behind
we gathered tonight a nation in mourning
to pay tribute to the lives we have lost
though we may be physically separated
we the american people are united
in spirit and my abiding hope
my abiding prayer is that we emerge from
this
ordeal with a new wisdom
but now i
see i mean this from the bottom of my
heart
for any angels in heaven they're all
nurses
we know from our family experience what
you do
the courage the pain you absorb
for others so thank you to heal
we must remember it's important
to do that as a nation let us shine the
lights
in the darkness along the sacred pool of
reflection
remember all whom we lost
i heard there was a secret court
that david played and it pleased the
lord
but you don't really care for music do
you
it goes like this the fourth the fifth
the minor fall and the major lift
the battle king composing
hallelujah
[Music]
hallelujah
hallelujah
[Music]
hallelujah
i know that there's a god above
and all i've ever learned from love
is how to shoot at someone who outdrew
you it's
not a cry you're here at night it's not
someone who's seen the light
it's a cold and it's a broken hallelujah
[Music]
hallelujah
hallelujah
hallelujah
[Music]
hallelujah
hallelujah
[Music]
[Applause]
hallelujah
[Music]
[Music]
sarah fuller with a chance to make
history and be the first woman in a
power fight football game
a goalkeeper on the vanderbilt soccer
team
sarah fuller will kick off for
vanderbilt
ladies and gentlemen you have witness
history here at pearl field
she can be the first to make an extra
point at the power five level
right through there entirely new
generation of girls that are gonna think
they can do more now because of what
you've done
i'm sarah fuller i faced a lot of
challenges as a goalkeeper on the
vanderbilt university women's soccer
team
and as a kicker on the football team but
seeing other women break barriers and be
the first at what they do
inspired me and gave me the strength to
succeed and that's why it is such an
honor to introduce a true groundbreaker
and after 232 years of waiting being
able to say these words
our nation's first woman vice president
vice president kamala harris
ladies and gentlemen the vice president
of the united states
kamala d harris
[Music]
good evening it is my honor to be here
to stand on the shoulders of those who
came before
to speak tonight as your vice president
in many ways this moment embodies our
character
as a nation it demonstrates who we are
even in dark times we not only dream
we do we not only see what has been
we see what can be we shoot for the moon
and then we plant our flag on it
we are bold fearless and
ambitious we are undaunted
in our belief that we shall overcome
that we will rise up
this is american aspiration
in the middle of the civil war abraham
lincoln saw a better future
and built it with land-grant colleges
and the transcontinental railroad in the
middle
of the civil rights movement dr king
fought for racial justice and economic
justice
american aspiration is what drove the
women of this nation
throughout history to demand equal
rights
and the authors of the bill of rights to
claim freedoms
that had rarely been written down before
a great experiment takes great
determination the will to do the work
and then the wisdom to keep refining
keep tinkering keep perfecting
the same determination is being realized
in america today i see it
in the scientists who are transforming
the future i see it in the
parents who are nurturing generations to
come in the innovators and the educators
in everyone everywhere who is building a
better life
for themselves their families and their
communities
this too is american aspiration
this is what president joe biden has
called upon us
to summon now the courage to see beyond
crisis
to do what is hard to do what is good
to unite to believe in ourselves
believe in our country believe
in what we can do together
thank you and may god bless america
and now john legend
birds flying high you know how i feel
sun in the sky you know how i
feel
drifting on by you know how i feel
it's a new dawn it's a new day
it's a new life for me
it's a new dawn it's a new day
a new life for me
[Music]
and i'm feeling good
[Music]
this embassy you know how i feel
[Music]
it's a new dawn it's
[Music]
and i'm feeling good
dragonfly out in the sun
[Music]
you know what i mean don't you know
butterflies are having fun
you know what i mean
sleep in peace one day it's done
that's what i made and this whole
world is a new world
[Music]
when you shine you know how i
feel
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
good
[Music]
[Music]
more inspiring stories are coming up on
celebrating america
ladies and gentlemen my name is dj
cassidy
and i'd like to welcome you all to
pastor mike inaugural edition
coming to you live as we celebrate
america president joe biden and vice
president kamala harris i said the party
has just begun
now today is the start of something new
it's a starter for coming together for
the soul of america
so i'm gonna pass the mic around the
nation to spread love from one home
to another let the celebration begin
you ready ozuna i'm ready cassidy let's
go
i'm ready too
[Music]
[Music]
um
oh
[Music]
let's celebrate america
[Music]
[Music]
thank you happy to be here let's
celebrate let's spread some love
[Music]
you look so beautiful
[Music]
[Music]
here we go
[Music]
um
now i'd like to thank azuna and luis
fancy my name is dj cassidy
and this is mastermind from my home to
yours
and around the nation we celebrate
america
to president and vice president harris
we stand with you in unity one love
share love
spread love
the celebration of america continues
during the past year as the pandemic
exploded across the country our nation's
doctors
and nurses put their lives on the line
yes
they did to keep us safe and to tend to
our ailments
the toll of these weeks of 24-hour
shifts was brutal
on our medical professionals they're
only human
but they found inventive ways to cope
with
superhuman demands
this crisis has showed the nation we
literally couldn't survive without you
i mean that sincerely we've been
protecting our communities for months
being called on once again as a virus
surges across the nation
but i want to thank you for everything
you're doing
to keep communities safe it's not
hyperbole you're heroes
i'm sandra lindsay an icu nurse at
northwell health in new york
and the first american to officially get
the covid vaccine
our nurses care for thousands of covid
patients daily
we're often the last people to hold
their hands
it has taken a toll on so many of us on
the front lines
but i'm proud of our work and honored to
represent
millions of healthcare workers around
the country
and now from nashville here are tyler
hubbard and tim mcgraw
to sandra lindsey and all of our health
care and frontline workers
thank you when i was in quarantine with
coven 19
i got to take a good hard look at myself
inspired by my faith in god to reunite
our country
i wrote this song and i sent it to tim
the song's message of unity and
faith stirred my soul and tonight
especially as we look across the river
at our strong resilient
beautiful city of nashville we're
honored to sing it for everyone
[Music]
she really got picked on in school
the things he couldn't change he tried
his best to play
cool but in the seventh grade you either
fit
right in or you don't if that's just the
cold hard truth
i wish that i'd have been the friend
that billy never knew
i think it's time to come together you
and i can make a change maybe we
can make a difference make the world a
better place
look around and love somebody we've been
hated
long enough let the good lord reunite us
to this
undivided yeah you either go to church
or you're gonna go to hell
get a job work or you're gonna go to
jail i just kind of wish we didn't think
like that
why's it gotta be all white or all black
but when we gonna learn
[Music]
[Music]
maybe we can make a difference make the
world a better place
look around and love somebody we've been
hated
long enough
[Music]
[Music]
we're all
[Music]
you and i can make a change maybe we
can make a difference make the world a
better place
[Music]
[Music]
church
[Music]
next presidents clinton bush and obama
and will be inside the white house for
our finale
celebrating america despite the
obstacles of the past year we've seen
americans support each other
time and time again today's parade
across america
a virtual road show featuring people
from across the country
paid a tribute to just some of these
american heroes
on the front lines of the pandemic
united to celebrate this
hopeful day
hello america we are honored to be here
today and want to be here today
to make american history again
let's get united america
like america we come from all over but
really we are one united team
we are
want to united
our american spirit allows us to have
hope
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we all believe that we are better when
we unite together
boom and they're born we salute our
commandment chief
joseph r our nation's first woman vice
president
vice president kamala harris it is the
honor of our lives an event that
connects
and unites americans
liberty equality and justice for all
all across america no matter who you are
or where you're from inspire others to
change the world bring joy and hope
let's get
united america
[Music]
now it's my honor to introduce three
people
to offer their reflections on what today
meant to them
and to our great country here are
presidents bill clinton
george bush and barack obama
well good evening america obviously
there was a personal element to see my
former vice president
uh become the 46th president to see
kamala harris as our first
woman vice president but
more broadly i think inaugurations
signal
a tradition of a peaceful transfer of
power that
is over two centuries old well i think
uh the fact that the three of us are
standing here talking about a peaceful
transfer of power speaks to the
institutional integrity of our country
so this is an
unusual thing we are both trying to come
back to normalcy
deal with totally abnormal challenges
and do what we do best which is try to
make a more perfect union it's exciting
time
we've gotta not just listen to folks we
agree with but listen to folks we don't
and one of my fondest memories of the
inauguration was
the the grace and generosity that
president
bush showed me and laura bush showed
michelle and
it was a reminder that we can have
fierce disagreements
uh and yet recognize each other's
common humanity and that as americans
we have more in common than what
separates us
i think if uh americans would uh love
their neighbor like they look
like to be loved themselves uh a lot of
the division in our society
would end that's what this means it's a
new beginning
and everybody needs to get off their
high horse
and reach out to their friends and
neighbors and
try to make it possible if in fact
as george said we're looking for what
binds us together
uh the american people are strong
they're tough uh
they can get through hardship uh and
there's no problem they can't solve when
we're working together i think that was
the theme of joe's inaugural speech and
uh i think all of us
discovered that we're at our best when
we're
all moving in the same direction america
is a generous country with people with
great hearts
all three of us were lucky to be the
president of this country
mr president uh i'm pulling for your
success
your success is our country's success
and god bless you
i'm glad you're there and i wish you
well
you have spoken for us today now you
will lead for us
and we're ready to march with you good
luck god bless you
joe i'm proud of you uh and you and
kamala
need to know that you've got all of us
here
rooting for your success keeping you in
our prayers
and we will be available in any ways
that we can as citizens
to help you guide our country forward
we wish you godspeed
when our former presidents unite like
that
much of the rest of the world must
marvel at what america is
that what americans can do
well now we'll celebrate more of
america's doctors and nurses
as they are joined by our friends and
neighbors for a performance of
lovely day in los angeles here's demi
[Music]
lovato
[Music]
when i wake up in the morning
[Music]
and the sunlight hurts my eyes
and something
[Music]
and the world's all right
[Music]
and i know it's gonna be
a lovely day
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
face
when someone else instead of me
i always seem to know the way i look at
you
[Music]
and i know it's gonna be
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
see it's
you know the way
[Music]
and i know it's gonna be
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen katy perry
do you ever feel like a plastic bag
drifting through the wind wanting to
start again
do you ever feel feel so paper-thin
like a house of cards won't blow from
caving
in
do you ever feel or any very deep
six feet on the screen
you know that there's still a chance for
you
cause there's a spark in you
ignite the light
and let it shine
[Music]
is
across the sky
[Music]
[Music]
you is have to feel like a waste of
space your original
cannot be replaced if you only knew
what the future holds after a hurricane
comes
[Music]
you'll
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
tonight
[Music]
[Music]
make them go
[Music]
[Music]
it's always been exciting
now it's time to let it go
as you should
[Music]
[Music]
oh
oh
[Music]
so
[Music]
bye oh yeah
fireworks in the sky over our nation's
capital
january 20th 2021
this has been a uniquely historic
inauguration day
thanks to all of our performers friends
and neighbors who celebrated america
with us
and once again congratulations
president biden and vice president
harris
god speed your efforts from the lincoln
memorial
good night america
[Music]
you